all right time now for the uplift at
eight the stories are gonna bring you
some joy on this
joy like that love some joy we love some
joy uh all right they say in life yeah
and life gives you lemons what do you
make lemonade
exactly right this is the story of how
making lemonade led to a sweet new
friendship one afternoon in new orleans
siblings chloe and milo and their friend
carly started a lemonade stand but it
was rainy and nobody came
yeah so 20 minutes later malik cornish
showed up and he bought some lemonade
and
he also bought some of chloe's dragon
artwork
chloe's mom recorded it all and posted
it on tick-tock watch
i had never met malik before and was
like who is this angel like he bought
everything they were saying and he was
smiling and interested and the kids were
just like on cloud nine after the
interaction i mean they literally like
came running inside like holding the
money we were like look look we did it
all right so after uh she posted this on
tick tock malik's phone started blowing
up
i was just going through my day just
hanging out and i get a dm from one of
my friends and she's like hey did you
get some lemonade earlier and i'm like
how do you know that and i look and i'm
like
this is crazy i'm looking at all the
messages people are giving me all nice
messages all the time and whatnot it's
just it's really heartwarming
yeah so here's the best part with some
help from the internet they were able to
meet up again and later chloe gave malik
a special custom drawing of a dragon
drinking lemonade
i love there
oh that's nice i love malik getting
calls did you buy someone exactly oh you
know that yeah
what's going on watching me that is nice
so we love this we've had riley earlier
in the show and what to watch and now
chloe the look of joy on a child's face
when you seem like nothing like that but
also the grown up in the picture here i
had a coach used to say character is
what you do when no one's looking oh
yeah no one's looking and he didn't
think he was going to end up on social
media getting exactly right
now
go malik